so caffeine TV is very much like a more
refined version of the application
twitch it's a place where people can
come together and share a broadcast and
have conversations around a shared
experience so could be watching an
individual play and narrate video
gameplay while others are in the same
room virtually commenting watching the
play and applauding it so so the basic
premise of caffeine TV is to create a
shared or communal experience around
television from a product standpoint one
of the cool things about caffeine is the
interaction between the the chat and the
person that is commentating over the
content is all in real-time
imagine if if it took up to 60 seconds
for you to react to what what I just did
like we'd lose a lot of the
entertainment I'd lose a lot of how I'm
interacting with you that's what real
entertainment comes from Ben is a serial
entrepreneur this is actually his third
startup he came to caffeine after
spending five years with Apple where he
worked on Apple TV and that experience
of working on Apple TV really sort of
informed his view about what the next
generation of television might be like
the initial applications are in eSports
arena so many of the the first users of
this technology are people like the game
who's a rapper or offset who go on to
this platform and they play a game so
therefore they're accessible to all
they're all their fans and the fans have
an opportunity to interact with them in
real time and get to share space with
them but long term the inventor of
caffeine hopes that this this very
easy-to-use platform will be able to be
used in other shared experiences like
music or other forms of entertainment
broadcast sports are predominantly
broadcast on linear television which
less and less people are watching the
various folks that buy the rights to
that the various folks that sell the
rights to different sports content are
looking for new ways to distribute the
content new ways for people to consume
the content new ways for people to pay
for the content caffeine is entering a
really crowded marketplace not only does
it have an established competitor like
twitch which has roughly 75% of all the
live-streaming market
place but they're also really
well-established competitors like
YouTube which has a service Microsoft
has its own service and it all enabled a
similar sort of a live streaming
experience caffeine has been in beta so
it's been a test form for a while it
emerged from that in November and it has
roughly a million users but it is a
fairly well capitalized for a start-up
it raised a hundred million dollars from
21st Century Fox back in 2018 prior to
Fox's acquisition by Disney and it has
well-regarded
members of its board of directors for
example Lachlan Murdoch who is a
descendant of media mogul Rupert Murdoch
and who runs Fox is on its board of
directors as is Ben Horowitz so he has
some pretty pretty well regarded
investors and board members I think one
interesting factor is the investment by
Fox Fox has a very large television
audience obviously but it's looking at
ways to reach audiences that aren't
necessarily tuned into its it's a very
popular sports broadcasts so I think
that this platform is is interesting
because it's a lens into a fast growing
phenomenon where there's where there's a
lot of money being invested and there's
also the further accelerant of
advertisers which are looking to reach
an audience that's not found on
traditional platform so so there's money
flowing and something is likely to
happen